bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans cette
vidéo qui va parler du film des éternels
de ces scène post générique de la fin du
film de ses mystères et c'est évidemment
la vidéo va spoil sévère le film des
éternels donc allé le voir avant de voir
cette vidéo vous êtes prévenus comme
vous avez vu j'ai tenté de faire un
petit décor un petit peu une envie de
changer et d'évoluer j'en avais un petit
peu marre du mur blanc donc vous me
direz ce que vous en pensez et puis bah
cela traduit aussi que je commence à
expérimenter à de nouvelles choses et du
coup pourquoi pas
redécouvrir l'univers et de paysages de
twitch donc voilà qui c'est on va en
reparler bref pour le moment on va
parler des éternels il y à de belles
choses à dire donc ne tardons pas on y
va let's go tout d'abord j'aimerais que
nous parlions du lien entre le film et
les comics car évidemment comme vous le
savez le mc ou réécrits à sa manière la
folle histoire de marvel des comics tout
en l'adaptant du coup pour les films et
les séries déjà la liaison amoureuse
entre tena et crocs dans les comics tena
qui est une éternelle et croquis et un
déviant ont une relation amoureuse
plutôt connue crocs pour rappel ces
genres la figure emblématique des
déviants le leader naturel de ces
derniers est bien dans le film le fait
que ce dernier absorbe les pouvoirs de
gilgamesh cela nous a donné un
affrontement entre tena et crau où ce
dernier prenait la voix de gilgamesh et
jouait sur cette référence comme si il
était amoureux bref vous avez compris
l'idée néanmoins le mc lui a fait des
choix plutôt particulier
et radicaux par moment puisque crowe est
mort et c'était une très grande surprise
pour moi tout dépend ce que prévoit
marvel pour les prochains films mais le
fait de tuer crowe dans eternalz
signifie pour moi que les déviants ne
seront pas plus exploité que ça puisque
déjà crowe est normalement la figure
emblématique de ces derniers leurs
représentants et c'est quelque chose qui
a été retranscrit dans le film puisque
cros était également le leader naturel
de ces derniers rappelez vous quand ils
regrettent les autres déviants après
avoir absorbé à jacques d'ailleurs c'est
aussi celui qui évolué constamment qui
avançait dans le film contrairement aux
autres à voir pour l'avenir du mc humer
les déviants été présenté comme une
menace secondaire laissant la place donc
au céleste et iq yaris et la fin nous
laisse suggérer que nous continuons dans
cette direction puisque valls éternel
ont une autre mission en tête et puis
bacrot est mort quoi en fait sachant
aussi qu'il n'ya plus d'éternel sur
terre et du coup normalement plus de
déviants non plus nous pouvons également
mentionné le cas de cha mode qui est
dans les comics le céleste rêveur il est
un céleste banni sur terre qui dort
depuis des milliers d'années la
référence aux comics est bien présente
dans le film puisque thiam hot d'or
entre guillemets dans les entrailles de
la terre pour naître ensuite j'aimerais
que nous parlions des éternels en
eux-mêmes et du k dick harris c'est
plutôt surprenant de voir autant de
morts et de disparition dans un groupe d
le premier film dans l'univers de marvel
que ce soit à jackie était là leader
spirituel du groupe ou même gilgamesh et
carris ou tout simplement bas aussi
sprite dont la fonction s'est arrêtée
mais tout ça au final c'est assez
cohérent déjà le fait de tuer à jacques
pour moi permet aux éternels de
s'émanciper de leur condition et de les
faire avancer vers une nouvelle
direction ils ont toujours été sous la
direction d'ajac et maintenant que ce
n'est plus le cas ils font face à de
nouvelles difficultés et son livre et à
eux mêmes ils n'ont plus de leaders
pareil pour gilgamesh envers tena c'est
quelque chose dont je suis convaincue
mais tena a été réduite dans eternalz
pour équilibrer le film rappelez vous
d'une infiniti voir avec hulk hulk n'a
jamais voulu réapparaître réduisant
considérablement la puissance de banner
tena avec sa maladie entre guillemets
dont j'ai oublié le nom a permis de la
réduire elle qui est normalement la plus
grande guerrière du monde et le fait que
guy diam s soit mort la force à sortir
de sa zone de confort et maîtrise et son
mal intérieur pour sprite son mal-être
était légitime et c'est un élément qui
revient dans les comics mais avant
d'aller plus loin sur ça il faut parler
dick harris effectivement
l'autodestruction dick harris est
d'importance déjà par rapport au film
hick harris a trahi les éternels et a
franchi le pas de non-retour en tuant à
jacques même si admettons il aurait
souhaité revenir dans le groupe
ce n'est pas fou de se dire que ton
coéquipier a délibérément décidé de tuer
un membre de la famille pour ses
convictions jamais le reste des éternels
ne l'aurais acceptée sauf que de l'autre
côté ycare is a également trahi les
célestes en se résignant à tuer thiam
août par rapport à son amour pour cerci
iq yaris est le grand perdant de
l'histoire et se retrouve dans une
impasse il a perdu sa famille et trahit
sa foi par rapport aux comics le film
semble s'être inspiré d'un moment
particulier pour cet événement pour
faire très simple les éternels vont
faire une découverte très sombre sur
leur origine
un lourd secret comme dans le film ils
doivent cultiver l'humanité car les
humains ont une
constitution génétique qui intéresse les
célestes car cela contre en gros une
sorte de race ennemis qui les menacent
sauf qu'à la découverte de ce fameux
secret justement les éternels vont
s'entre déchirer se disputent et se
combattre allant même jusqu'à s'auto
détruire pour certains dont hikari ce
même si les raisons sont différentes
dans le m6 où nous retrouvons cette
mission secrète cachée par les célestes
envers les éternels ils doivent cultiver
l'humanité et cette découverte va
déchirer le groupe la mort dick harris
serait une référence à cet événement
tout le film repose là-dessus toute
façon en revanche est ce véritablement
la fin pour lui eh bien c'est ce que
nous allons voir car nous rentrons dans
un nouveau point important rappelez vous
que les éternels peuvent être risette et
reforger et que cela arrive même dans
les comics là où je vous disais qu'ils
caris s'était autodétruit il a été
ramené par les célestes ultérieurement
et il n'est pas le seul ces derniers ont
une chambre de réactivation comme dans
le mc arish m nous a amenés l'origine
des éternels où il disait qu'il avait
été créé dans une forge dont le nom
m'échappe et du coup par rapport à ça
sprite pourrait être reforger également
mais bon son histoire semble s'arrêter
là puisqu'elle n'est plus une ethernet
en revanche y carisse a toutes les
chances de réapparaître mais avec une
nouvelle mémoire
tout comme à jacques ou encore gilgamesh
néanmoins la logique voudrait que iq
yaris ne reviennent jamais en tant que
leader charismatique du groupe tout
simplement car une nouvelle figure fait
surface il est temps de parler de star
fox star fox de son vrai nom eros est un
éternel mais pas n'importe lequel il est
le frère de thanos sa particularité en
tant qu éternel également et que son
pouvoir signature est on va dire la
séduction un peu comme druide qui peut
manipuler les gens star fox peut séduire
les gens les rendre sympathique et à son
égard on va dire et c'est en plus
évidemment de volée et d'avoir des
capacités surhumaines alors évidemment
on comprend mieux pourquoi harry styles
se joue le rôle un beau gosse qui joue
un beau gosse vous avez compris l'idée
mais surtout de par son palmarès sa
famille ses pouvoirs et tout simplement
sa venue dans une scène post générique
et bien il est là le potentiel nouveau
leader charismatique des éternels qui
remplacerait iq yaris d'ailleurs petit
mot sur people troll c'est un personnage
fun un peu anecdotique des comics mais
je trouve que sa présence prouve quelque
chose d'intéressant il est le compagnon
qui sert un peu de mascotte aeros et ça
appuie encore plus son importance pour
l'avenir je pense on retrouve le délire
de personnage important accompagné d'une
petite entité qui l'accompagnent un
petit peu comme je sais pas moi j'aurai
dans star wars avec bébé 8 le plus
intéressant concernant star fox c'est
que cela valide encore plus les origines
de thanos et le lien avec les comics
puisque star fox est le frère de thanos
est en hausse dans une finity voir a été
accueilli par red skull qui l'a nommé en
tant que fils d'allah ce qui est le
véritable père de thanos et et rose dans
les comics et un grand éternelle il
existe une possibilité ou
on va explorer un petit peu plus en
détail l'histoire de cette famille mais
c'est beaucoup trop tôt pour affirmer
quoi que ce soit néanmoins étant donné
que starfox est toujours en vie qu'il
semble vouloir aider les éternels et
même se joindre à eux cela signifie
qu'il possède le même mode la même
penser que les éternels doivent savoir
la vérité ce qui sous-entend qu'il est
contre les célestes et que certainement
il a déjà fait face à une situation
dramatique liée à ces derniers et c'est
là que nous pouvons penser à titan la
planète ou thanos eros et leurs parents
vivaient rappelez-vous la planète
étaient destinés à mourir est en hausse
avait émis l'idée de tuer 50 % de la
planète de façon impartiale et
aléatoires ce qui lui a valu d'être
désigné comme le titan fou et a été
banni de la planète mais du coup est ce
que la planète n'était pas destiné à
mourir justement à cause d'un jugement
des célestes d'éradiquer titans et du
coup star fox aurait dû fuir ou peu
importe il a survécu mais il aurait
compris l'ampleur des célestes et du
sacrifice
inacceptable d'être vivant innocent à
cause de leur volonté il y à vraiment
des zones d'ombré intéressante à
explorer dans tous les cas ces derniers
vont chercher d'autres éternelle et cela
pourrait faire l'objet d'une autre vidéo
mais il y a vraiment beaucoup de
possibilités pour les éternels on est
vraiment là dans une nouvelle ère de
marvel et enfin un petit mot sur des
rythmes and ce dernier est bien
évidemment le chevalier noir un célèbre
héros de marvel et dernier possesseur de
la lame d'ébène une lame maudite cet ep
a traversé l'héritage de la famille de
dane et plusieurs possesseurs ont fait
des dingueries avec comme abusé de son
pouvoir et tu es beaucoup de gens ce qui
fait que l'épée est maudite en gros dane
face à la capacité de pouvoir aider
serre s'ils souhaitent empoigné l'épée
de sa famille et c'est ce qu'il fera
mais une voix l'interrompt pour lui
demander s'il est sûr de vouloir le
faire pour moi il s'agit forcément de
son oncle et je vais vous expliquer
pourquoi déjà dans la cohérence du film
cerci après avoir quitté dun l'appel
dans la forêt où ils vont chercher
druide pour reformer les éternels et
bien cette scène n'a vraiment aucune
utilité à part justement amenée
l'information que dane à un oncle et que
justement l'autre information c'est que
dane est en conflit avec ce fameux oncle
puisque cerci affirmera aden qu'il est
temps de se réconcilier avec son oncle
puisque basse et possiblement la fin du
monde quoi mais du coup des nains oncle
ils sont en conflit à quoi ça sert de
s'appuyer là dessus eh bien il faut
retourner dans les comics puisque
l'oncle de dane de son vrai nom nathan
garrett est le dernier possesseur de la
lame d'ébène même si cette dernière ne
l'a jamais autorisé à la manier le souci
étant que nathan garrett a été une sorte
de vilains qui a fait beaucoup de
mauvais choix et a regretté ses actes sa
rédemption lui a valu de léguer son
château et l'épée familial à son neveu
dane avant de mourir et bien c'est
possiblement la raison de la relation
distante entre jane et son oncle puisque
dane est déjà en possession de l'épée et
que son oncle semble l'épaule et au
moment où ils souhaitent l'empoigné cela
veut dire que dane connaît déjà toute
l'histoire de sa famille ce qui est le
cas et de son oncle du coup en tout cas
des n'y aura certainement un grand rôle
pour l'avenir du mc eu c'est clair mais
je pense que nous aurons une série
disney plus dédiée à ce personnage
puisque c'est un petit peu la nouvelle
stratégie de marvel de produire des
séries sur des personnages un petit peu
secondaire mais qui vont devenir très
grand par la suite genre par exemple on
a le cas avec moonlight ou she hulk ou
même par exemple agathe harkness même si
c'est pas vraiment une héroïne enfin
voila je pense avoir dit beaucoup de
choses et j'espère que la vidéo vous
aura plu n'hésitez pas à me dire ce que
vous avez pensé du film eternal dans les
commentaires personnellement j'ai
beaucoup aimé j'ai eu des échos comme
quoi ce avait divisé pas mal de monde
mais personnellement moi j'ai pas mal
apprécié et je trouve que ça a été une
belle origin story comparé à de
précédentes origin story justement dans
dans les films marvel il y a des chances
que je vous propose dans les prochains
jours pourquoi pas un trois théories sur
l'avenir des éternels par exemple mais
bon il faut que je pense à de belles
théories donc voila cela reste à voir je
promets rien de belles vidéos arrivent
en tout cas je suis content d'avoir
changé de décor j'ai encore des choses à
améliorer et cetera et puis la question
de twitch est très légitime un j'y pense
de plus en plus et j'ai même commencé
déjà à préparer quelques petits trucs en
attendant n'hésitez pas à laisser un
petit pouce bleus c'est très important à
vous abonner aussi à la chaîne c'est
encore plus important et puis écouter
bas que le lionheart soit avec vous
écoutez c'était un roc allez ciao
tomates
[Musique]